le président de la république prendra la
parole pour une grande interview de deux
heures demain soir il a enregistré
dimanche est ce que vous savez ce qu'il
va nous raconter allez je suis j'en suis
désolé mais pas le monument mieux nous
faire un petit mais
nature non alors sage j'ai pas d'infos
jeu j'en ai quelques doutes
alors quand est ce qu'ils ne connaissent
que nous
saisissions déjà je ne sais pas s'il
annoncera sa candidature et je c'est une
décision qui est je suis 2es jeux des
trucs c'est la langue de bois mais c'est
la réalité c'est une décision qui
n'appartient qu'à lui seul
parole du chef de l'état demain soir
soit décompté de sa campagne à ce
qu'elle n'a pas raison de dénoncer une
campagne sous couvert de comté
présidentielle c'est à ses traditions
ses traditionnels qu'en fin d'année
comme ça le chef de l'état prenne la
parole pour s'adresser aux français le
président la république l'avait déjà
fait l'année dernière sous d'autres
formats souvenez vous
c'est pas le même quand vous dans
l'express il avait parlé sur brut
d'ailleurs l'époque
particulière oui enfin arrivé une fois
encore c'est assez traditionnel par un
chef de l'état s'adresser aux français
en fin d'année comme ça je pense que les
présidents précédents la belle avait
aussi fait d'ailleurs je temps de
regarder
enregistré dimanche à les diffuser le
soir valérie pécresse devait faire une
grande émission il ya un peu
d'inquiétude
dans la majorité présidentielle
vis-à-vis de la candidature de valérie
pécresse franchement je ne pense pas que
la date a été fixée en fonction de ce
que faisait valérie pécresse sur une
autre chaîne jusqu'au incident mais je
ne doute pas que ça c'est une grande
interview de valérie pécresse sera à
reprogrammer un autre jour il reste pas
mal de soirées d'ici à l'élection
présidentielle valérie pécresse aura
tout loisir de s'exprimer sur la
question dorian sur la concurrence de
valérie pécresse vis-à-vis des manuels
macron qu'est ce que vous en pensez
ici quand même est-ce qu'elle n'est pas
en train de ramener l'électorat de
droite qu'emmanuel mac on écoute les
conquérir
écoutez franchement déjà déjà mais je
suis pas encore hyper au clair sur le
positionnement politique irréel de
valérie pécresse en pour l'instant
bahreïn est un petit écart tellement
quand même entre vous avez beaucoup
parlé de michel barnier donc que je
respecte plus tôt qui était qui
bénéficiait du soutien de bernard gones
dernier d'un côté et puis eric ciotti
qui quand même semble avec ses 40% au
second tour d'affaires qui m'ont étonné
un très sincèrement je pensais pas qu'il
serait aussi haut et qui donc va peser
dé facto sur le positionnement politique
nouvelle a été créée ce qui va me risque
donc d'être ramené un peu plus vert vert
vers sa droite donc non j'ai pas trop
d'un coup surtout enfin j'ai envie de
vous dire
enfin nous pour l'instant on bosse
jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure nous a
demandé le président de la république
oui on a ouvert beaucoup de dossiers
merci de m'avoir invité pour en évoquer
quelques uns ce matin et je pense que
une des meilleures façons pour présents
dans le public de se faire rayer ainsi
les candidats c'est que nous fassions ce
que nous avions dit que nous ferons et
que nous allions jusqu'au bout de mon
travail jusqu'au bout pour les français
voilà c'est ce qu'on s'évertue à faire
[Musique]